- Entschuldigen Sie, dass ich Sie störe.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
- Sie stören nicht.
Bitte, setzen Sie sich.
- Ich habe leider nicht viel Zeit.
Ich habe kurzfristig zwei Tickets
für eine spannende Kulturveranstaltung
in der Stadt bekommen.
Es wird eine sehr interessante
Ausstellung geben
und ein neues Theaterstück
wird aufgeführt.
Danach gibt es noch einen
tollen Film im Kino.
- Das klingt interessant.
- Ja, das ist auch sehr interessant, weil
die Ausstellungen das aktuelle Thema
„Flucht und Heimat“ haben.
Und ich dachte,
es wäre vielleicht schön,
wenn Selma mich begleitet.
- Selma hat dafür leider keine Zeit.
- Ibrahim! Du solltest Selma gehen lassen.
- Also mich würde interessieren,
wobei ich dir helfen soll,
weil ich deine Eltern gerade
eiskalt anlügen musste.
- Es tut mir leid, es war eine Notlüge!
Ich muss zu Nico!
Weißt du, wo er ist?
- Ja komm! Wir müssen uns beeilen!